i was throwing [ __ ] i'm trying to figure
[ __ ] out but you gotta remember in the
midst of that
wayne is wayne drake
is drake and he's only coming bigger
nikki is nikki and the barbie is only
becoming bigger
so now we got to sustain this
we got to sustain wayne nicky drake
tiger's doing his thing but they're
keeping the lights on nikki and drake
kept the lights on
when wayne went to rikers island keeping
it a buck right
so now all right now we're touring
all right well how do we do the tours
now whoa
who's gonna open who's gonna close who's
gonna open who's gonna close or oh he's
not going out with us he's going out on
his own or she's doing her own tour
she's take so now i'm peeping like
this when i realized
this [ __ ] is really really different and
it happened fast i remember drake did
club paradise that was the name of drake
yeah i was hot
what were you hot about i loved drake
but i was hot
i think me and i think me and gutta
gutter might have been i don't know if
gutter was too hot
but i was hot and i think i was hot
because i was thinking something was
going to go a certain way
like did you think you were supposed to
be on the tour yes
i will come exactly was that the
kendrick asap rocky tour that was every
that was
that was basically everybody that was
doing the same thing that we were doing
at that time that wasn't with young
money
i remember that i remember and i love
drake i ain't gonna lie i love drake
with
all my heart man i love nikki i love
tiger
wayne gutter macmain twist i love all
the everybody that was a part of that
ride
with young money whether we still cause
me and tiger not young money no more but
i always
i'm not covering my young money tattoo
like i still sign my checks and you
still see it
because that was a decade of my life
that was a that was like a real period
of my life
but there were a lot of times that in
that period i started to see
oh we're label mates we homies
but we're we're label mates and you
can't you can't forget that because
you didn't grow up with these people you
met these people on some business [ __ ]
so don't don't don't don't get yourself
kicking in your laker reference
people get traded people people get
traded at this time we still got the
same uniform on
right so i'm looking at it like damn i
would have thought we could at least
open up you know what i'm saying like
though
take us out there like tune took you or
or nikki too you know what i'm saying
like take us out there like
you took dead loaf or this one and
this one even if we not hot like that
make us hot somebody made you hot
now once again to be fair to be fair
this is just me and my feelings at that
time
as a younger artist you're like i'm in
my feelings because i'm like yo we crew
we we didn't both had to go chase
the tour people around for pedium before
like
did you communicate that to drake or did
drake ever like know that you you were
once again what i'm saying is at that
time we were in our feelings about [ __ ]
i'm saying that he find out
jake might have been in his feelings
about [ __ ] with us that we don't know
about
you know he might have been in his
feelings with [ __ ] about wayne or tez or
you know what i'm saying there was times
that wayne might have been in his
feelings with some [ __ ] about ted's and
drake might have paid for it
you know what i'm saying like it might
have been sometimes that
wayne wasn't he just wasn't [ __ ] with
new york and when i walk in the room
it's just like
[ __ ] old new york ass [ __ ] no it's
not like the end of the world it's not
in person but
you got to think when you were around
people as long as we was around each
other young money [ __ ] was a long
ride that [ __ ] wasn't like no two three
year
you hot and then you hear it's like nah
we all went from one bus
we was all on wayne bus to now it's
wayne bus
and an artist bus now we all on the
artist bus to now it's wayne buster
artist bus drake bus nicki busted band
bust the dancers bus
the chef bust the crew like that [ __ ]
changed i went from doing clubs to
performing in front of when i say j.u
say mills jay
jay where you at milsie and my my [ __ ]
come on and i'm like damn i never heard
people scream for me like that
right so it was a hell of a ride but in
in along that ride you did learn [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying you did learn
that yo drake don't got to do nothing
for you
right nothing now once i got that
through my head
i was cool it's like yo i don't know i'm
not tripping if he come out with
six or seven albums and i'm not on none
of them i could still find the dopeness
in the [ __ ] album it's like it's cool
bro
it's not the end of the world if
somebody don't
pull you along like especially if you
never told me you was going to pull me
along and you
it's all in your head